student Libby Squire disappeared during
a night out in Hull in January 2019. her
body was found seven weeks later in the
Humber estuary
paulwell relevich denied killing her but
the evidence was compelling he'd
followed her he'd raped her somehow he'd
killed her
he's now serving a 27-year sentence for
Libby's murder but her mother Lisa wants
to know more and she's requested to meet
him
but we don't know how she died there are
lots of questions I have still like you
know whereabouts was she put in the
river what part of the the field did you
put her into the river
really you know
send us the questions I suppose did you
put her in head first or feet first was
she crying was she cold all these
different questions that I have going
around my head 24 7 and he is the only
person that could answer them and he has
agreed to meet you in principle yes yeah
I mean he's obviously a compulsive liar
oh he has to as well as a Monster yeah
and so you don't know whether he's going
to play with you or manipulate you and
certainly whether he'll ever tell you
the truth so I'm just wondering whether
you really what you really gained from
it I need to do it for me and I don't
I've never met him I've never been in
the same space as the person who was
last with my daughter and that for me is
really important you are under arrest
for the murder rape Libby Square
a new Sky documentary reveals new
footage of relevich smirking as he's
told by police he is suspected of murder
that to me wasn't I didn't take it as he
was mocking or you know laughing at the
situation to me that was very much like
oh god I've been caught you know it's
like almost like a nervous laugh you're
laughing there the killer also seems to
smirk through police interviews why are
you smoking Lisa knows he's never shown
any remorse nor admitted guilt he's
still claiming he's innocent yeah but he
didn't stand up I'm gonna tell you what
happened no but I mean he won't he's not
going to tell me exactly what happened I
know that he won't tell me now he might
tell me in a few years and and I'm I'm
not naive enough to think he's going to
say oh I did this and she died but I
hope one day she will because it's
really hard not knowing how your child
died
in grief Lisa just wants truth and knows
she may never get it but she's
determined to try
Jason Farrell Sky News